my last visit with my dad
I couldn't stop telling him how great
that he looked
um he looks very very good
um I told him I said even your hair
looks better a little bit longer and a
little bit grayer we have the struggles
that everyone else has and we work
through them as a family
new details about Todd Chrisley's new
reality Behind Bars you want to be
strong and tell them that everything's
going to be fine even though you're
questioning if everything's going to be
fine Lindsey Chrisley goes there on her
Southern tea podcast what we will not do
is we will not break nearly three months
after her parents surrendered to prison
following their convictions for bank
fraud and tax evasion my parents were
were welcomed with open arms and I I
feel so blessed with that because I have
heard of you know other people reporting
and and that not being the case I will
say it's really weird seeing him with
gray hair Savannah Chrisley shocked by
her dad salt and pepper look but her
sister Lindsay she's here for it my last
visit with my dad
I couldn't stop telling him how great
that he looked
um he looks very very good
um I told him I said even your hair
looks better a little bit longer and a
little bit grayer but he's definitely
used some color over the years and now
seeing Kim with gray hair I'm like oh my
gosh this is a close family and they're
obviously going to spend time visiting
with one another any family who faces a
loved one going to prison
um it's a very difficult challenge one
of those challenges the commute between
Mom and Dad we're going to Florida it's
pastel season Todd's facility is in the
Sunshine State meanwhile Julie's
655 miles away from him in Kentucky my
dad never
surrendered himself to
the federal prison camp in Pensacola
thinking that he was going to a Taj
Mahal one of my biggest concerns was the
access to televisions do you think that
people have seen Chrisley Knows Best
that are serving time in these camps and
simply the answer I know the answer now
is yes a bunch of family therapists
something that this family needs
drastically every day we have a fan base
now that that we want to make them proud
We want them looking up to us not
looking down on us he is really just
embracing the process there and making
the best of the process there with the
people that are also there serving time
with him he's made great friends we made
a commitment that we were not going to
give up if Todd and Julie could share a
message with the world what do you think
they'd want them to know I think they'd
want folks to know that they are the
same people they've always been that
they didn't do these things and they're
going to fight to get their name cleared
foreign